ambassador Bolton thank you very much
for sparing us time I want to start on
the issue of Venezuela there are now
Russian personnel on the ground in
Venezuela what is your message to Moscow
well as the president said a couple of
days ago the Russians need to get out we
view this as a threat to international
peace and security in the region you
know one of the purposes of the Monroe
Doctrine was to prevent the
recolonization of the Western Hemisphere
when you look at this Russian military
presence together with the Cuban
military presence long-standing military
presence in Venezuela we're very worried
that the true wishes of the Venezuelan
people will not be heard so it's a
matter of great concern to us does this
cross a line for you do you intend to
respond with action well the president
has been clear repeatedly all options
are on the table we have not militarily
intervened in Venezuela that's clear but
Russia and Cuban military forces are
there that's not a good situation again
for the people of Venezuela we spoke
just a week ago with this threat posed
by Russia does military action now look
more possible well I don't want to get
into weighing what the options might be
in that sense we wanted to make it very
clear to Russia China Cuba anybody who
might be assisting the Maduro regime
that we consider Maduro illegitimate and
we consider assistance to his government
contrary to the best interest of the
Venezuelan people we don't want to see
this escalate we've said repeatedly we
want a peaceful transition from the
Maduro regime to juan do i do't that
remains our objective
teresa made in the UK has now suffered
her third defeat does the prospect of a
quick UK US trade deal now look less
likely I think to the contrary you know
people who worry about the UK crashing
out of the European Union that's the
phrase they use they're going to crash
right into the United States we're
standing here waiting to make a trade
deal with an United Kingdom independent
of the European Union I don't want to
get into the specifics of what's been
going on in the House of Commons but I
can say on
typically that President Trump is eager
for the will of the British people to be
carried out and he's even more eager to
do a trade deal it does now look know
that we may remain in the customs union
and we understand that that was a red
line for the administration before is it
not anymore
the the president wants to be able to
deal with a Britain that can change some
of the rules of trade that we think this
favor of the United States when it's in
connection with the European Union and
honestly from the US point of view and
for that matter the UK point of view I
don't understand why you'd want to get
out of the European Union but not to be
able to set your own rules that's what
independence means and that's what the
president wants to do he thinks that the
EU rules discriminate against American
trade and he wants a free fair and
reciprocal trade deal with Great Britain
does a deal they depend on us leaving
that customs union well as I understand
it if you don't have the ability to make
your own rules if you're still subject
to Brussels then you're not independent
but it really is quite important to the
president I think too so that people in
Britain know that this is the top of the
priority this is not the Obama
administration where Britain would go to
the back of the queue which of course is
not an American phrase Britain will be
at the top of the queue for us what
about Theresa Mays leadership she has
suffered now some significant defeats is
it time for her to step aside well I
think that's not for me to say the
president had some kind words for this
morning and I think he does consider her
a friend and he knows what it's like to
go through difficult leadership
situations the president had some kind
words to say about Boris Johnson as well
do you think that he would make a good
leader an alternative to Teresa may well
I wouldn't want to do anything to to
interfere and in deliberations that the
Conservative Party and and others would
make it really is up to today man Delta
mately to the British people do you
think a general election is
well you're you're persistent questioner
but I'm not going to get into that one
either we're ready for a trade deal
that's really what I would like to say
what does that trade deal look like in
your mind well I think between two
powerful global economies like the
United Kingdom and the United States all
kinds of possibilities are present in
the financial services area in trade and
goods and services I think that Canada
would come to such a trade deal very
quickly and I think others would as well
for us it's very exciting the
restrictive rules and practices of the
European Union have been a real drag on
transatlantic trade and so I think
that's one reason the president thought
that a bilateral trade deal with an
independent Britain would be
advantageous to both countries Nigel
Farage describes this is a day of shame
for Britain and called for a revolution
is he right
I think Britain had a referendum I think
the leave vote one and what everybody
agrees with it was a free and fair
election doesn't the will of the British
British people get to be carried out is
it a shameful moment I don't really want
to get into that I think it's a very
difficult moment I think everybody in
Britain agrees it all I can say is the
American people want to help the British
people when your independence comes
where we want a trade deal and
ambassador in Mexico today we heard from
the president in a tweet this morning
that if Mexico does not end illegal
immigration then he will close vast
sections of that border next week we
have heard this threat before does he
mean it I think when the president
speaks he he means that that's been my
experience repeatedly I think he sees a
crisis on the border I think he hoped
that Mexico would be able to do more I
think we're in discussions with the
Mexicans and others in the hemisphere
it's a big problem for us and the
president made this one of his signature
issues in the 2016 campaign so he's very
serious about it so they're talking
about potentially a major meet next week
that's certainly what he indicated and
as I say this is something that is
personally very very important to him
ambassador Bolton thank you very much
for your time I appreciate it